no reason to write I mean you know what  when you when you're young cry trash  different got like once you get close to  four years Oh like nine natural causes  [ __ ] like that right four years old in  shape you know my friend Dustin just  come back you guys know who Howard  Bingham is famous photographer so Howard  Bingham son Dustin I go to college this  is when my best friend's come in Bob and  his brother Damon he could be Ollie  movie with Will Smith pass away if I'm  crazy  Ali died a man died and Howard Bingham  died that you might've saw always in  like a year yeah four hundred trillion  to one  you know that's my I talk about  everything like well not when I think  about the fact that my dad could have  you know the side take a [ __ ] and like  like you know how hard it is to become a  human like like 400 trillion for one  like there's no math like you can win  like ninety NBA championships in a row  more likely than being a human being  [Music]